um how much of your time were you do
because you know you think like if
you're an artist you're a rapper you
have time to write did you get out with
just like notebooks full of [ __ ] yeah I
got out like five minutes just ready to
go yeah I gotta keep it with me yeah so
you you still got the the notebooks you
got it on me right now can we see him
yeah break this [ __ ] out dude let's see
because I always wonder that like
like I feel like if I was as talented as
you are I was like yo I'm going to take
this time to write songs which is what
you did
walk in here and say right now come to
this game I gotta follow the rest often
do that right here right now I'm trying
to make that money right here right now
like
yeah you got hundreds of thousands of
dollars worth of guest verses ready to
go
now
Jesus
well
I bet hey when you win and you win it
[ __ ]
I see this here I don't want to touch
your bag I don't know what else you got
in there
maybe another [ __ ] hundred thousand
dollars or something who knows
yo all this [ __ ] so this is all from
jail yeah all this [ __ ] from the jail
that [ __ ] from the bump this is crazy
man is there any organization to this
you just kind of go through it fine out
of all this [ __ ] I probably didn't drop
like 50 of them this is [ __ ] can we show
the show this camera
this is crazy hey that's my set right
there
it might mean all right that is my
they're my m um do you you pull from
this still yeah yeah that's what I work
out for that's amazing man that's what I
work out for right here
that's amazing oh
yeah
yeah
rappers you still got it right man stop
playing yeah put that pen to that paper
I'm gonna get that pin that pass so I'm
good and that don't get me wrong
something good yeah they are but I do
feel like when you write it it's more
like every line has more of a purpose as
to where when you punch in I feel like
you're kind of trying to rush through
[ __ ] yeah you're just saying [ __ ] and
you be and like every every engineer
appreciate it every engineer that I'd
have ran across they'd be like damn I
ain't never seen nobody record their
[ __ ] fast
I go in there like I probably could
knock 10 songs out
an hour I'll be done like yeah I mean I
mean I'm I've been I mean I have
recorded studio so I've been in the
studio with a lot of artists and the
punching [ __ ] I understand the like I
understand why people do it but at the
same time if you're if you're an
engineer I can understand
all right remember me back right here
this guy knows he's done it a million
times but no it's that's that's not I
just did not just because I got it on
paper but like I said I use my time
constructively like so a lot of time
when I was in the sale I used to just
believe it or not go through this [ __ ]
page but paid wow and just rip it and
then like when I get tired I I bookmark
or I stopped it the next day let's do it
again that's amazing man now you're
sitting there [ __ ] by myself
and just go like all right they just
need to say this and they need to come
back like this anything
yeah yeah